as you know I came on the air and like
Danny dimes stinks
blows right he did had no idea you know
cuz good morning footballs on at a very
early very early out here I had no idea
Peter Schreyer had the same sense and
brought that to the television people on
NFL Network this morning Peter you there
sir yeah I'm here rich we are just like
minded people right now so the purity
and sanctity of good nickname it blows
it blows doing personal terrible do we
know where did Danny dimes come from do
we know I don't know I don't know and I
don't like it and I don't want to
announce it or have a nickname just yet
I want to let this thing marinate right
I feel like it'd be shove down our
throat to the collective nation I agree
I agree so as you know Peter you and I
are lockstep not only on this but we're
also people who like to improve we don't
just we don't just criticize we'd like
to improve so what what have you what
have you on earth what have you come up
with as a possible switch here Peter we
obviously talked about it on the show we
put it to Twitter a couple good ones
okay what he got Steely Dan I like
Steely Dan hit with me daniel Jones
Steely Dan a very revered musical group
of course but he's got that steely
demeanor and it's a throwback to a
different era of music when it wasn't
just all crap and junk feeling banned to
me really had no what'd you think of
that one was right here's what I would
say is that it's it's Steely Dan is is
is as you point out a certain brand of
music that doesn't get made much anymore
it's it's borderline yacht rocky and and
for somebody like Daniel Jones who is 20
what to 22 but but he acts he acts 52
kind of like a Steely Dan does seem like
it's beyond his years and he acts again
like somebody who would go to a Steely
Dan concert and sway to you don't seem
like a Yacht rock guy Charlotte Latin
principal wearing the Lacoste polo I
think he could be stealing and the other
one we got
yes which actually came from the Culver
newsdesk it was from well so who said
the Duke and an honor and a tip of the
hat to Wellington Mara
course we will Jones went to Duke I know
that we rejected that out of hand like
the Giants are not going to allow a
nickname to to to be similar to
Wellington Mehra's it nicknames on the
ball for crying out loud
and you also got you also got John
Elway's is the Duke and I will have to
reject that one Steely Dan is one that
we I think could be a headline writer
but it's not like something again that
somebody's gonna say in in in a in a
game like you know I mean I just
so Rocklin which ones do we have that we
can share with more sure go for the one
last one is any times it's cool whatever
it's very internet the currency of the
moment though is not nickels pennies
dimes
it's crypto so I said Danny crypto is a
lot cooler he's faster than regular
occurrence he's more new-age he's very
2019 Danny crypto like a Bitcoin that
one hit for me I know Danny crypto Danny
crypto okay it rolls off the tongue the
thing is he's just so it's it's like
Danny milquetoast I mean there's no he's
not cool buddy I'm sure he might be in
person but he is just flat-out Eli 2.0
that's maybe his nickname eli 2.0 I mean
is look after Eli was too cumbersome to
comfort what did we come up with Chris
what if our listeners we got downtown
Danny dapper damn no
legend Danny legend Danny we got Danny
dazzle no Danny tassel that's worse than
I take Danny times over Danny dazzle
Daniel Boone the Dan chose Daniel boom
the dan chives that's not a bad one you
know or we just agree to disagree and
the guy just he's not a nickname guy Oh
Danny dimes because he's dropping dimes
out there because it is sounds like a
Goodfellas character I understand
but he's not all that guy he's not a
Danny dimes terrible fan base this fan
base has cannibalized and galvanize are
that where I even said I said on
Erickson I kind of think Danny dimes is
lame and I thought that would be like
whatever a throwaway comment I got
hundreds of tweets me like sugar you're
lame shut up like people do not want to
hear that they love their Danny but
Peter you are like again you're like
coach Dale all right and now and the
fans are yelling at you there's
screaming at you they think you're nuts
you just wave your beliefs in your
leather satchel and say your team's on
the floor Peter don't listen to those
people
damn straight and Danny dives blows
thanks for the call Peter appreciate it
appreciate it he's sitting there right
there there is Brucie Brucie Brucie
nickels right there there's Brucie
nickels thanks the call Peter thank for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app